Peggy 18
sorry I've got to go
stay safe Barbara you still know how to
make an entrance
any lead on scarecrow we were tracking
an unknown military vehicle speeding
through Chinatown it's the only lead
we've had all night but they gave us the
slip if you find it tell your men not to
engage I'll deal with it do you really
think scarecrows crazy enough to
detonate a chemical weapon and Gotham I
won't let that happen Jim we got a 1033
in Sector two patrol car hey Batman
every damn time
Oracle I need the location of unit 247
already working on it
how's my dad doing he's holding up
somehow he always does okay I'm sending
through this war cars location be
careful it's not looking good out there
you
where's hourly anyway
crying yet I want to make it cry
what's a log yeah I fought Batman once
broke my arm
this is good
I can use some help here
you're safe thanks Batman
I thought they were gonna kill me
the city's overrun we don't stand a
chance
stay here I'll send someone to pick you
up what are you doing evening the odds
the hell did they get their military
hardware
Oracle I need to track that military
vehicle a squad cars picked up the
pursuit I'm weighing its location now
all of your mid-gulf Oscar 5:6 this is
Commissioner forth
assume it's to name
they just were not beating us
five six collective that's an order
let that man deal with this places he
can interact in from an RPG they're gone
sir
please Batman you've gotta stop Joker
being a builder
to interrogate the driver and find out
what he knows
get away from me
where's scarecrow go to hell where is he
I got nothing to say to Batman talk or
I'll crush every bone in your body
okay okay working out of a pet house in
Chinatown I swear that's all I know if
you're lying I'll break the other one
the other one
Oracle check the chemical analysis I've
just uploaded sure is this what I think
it is Scarecrow's new toxin an
uncontaminated sample you're not kidding
I'll prepare a full chemical breakdown
on the back computer what are you going
to do
scarecrows got a safe house nearby I'm
going to pay him a visit
let's hope this is the break we've been
waiting for
right
you